thank you so much for being here
congratulations on a beautiful movie
um I know that this is the featured
directorial debut of Elegance Bratton
which I actually kind of can't get over
because it's so beautiful and so assured
um and I would just love to know um how
you first became aware of this project
and what interested you in bringing it
to the screen
he's like I'm the husband
well I'm elegance's producer and partner
um I'm Chester
um we are married so I helped him
develop the script on the archouch
essentially it was between uh
a short film based off of I mean sorry a
feature film based off of a short film
walk for me that had some Festival
success and then this film and um we had
a conversation and I told Elegance he
should do the story that only he can
tell essentially and you know take the
viewers through what he's gone through I
mean I know all movies are
autobiographical to some degree but this
is this is a pretty personal story for
him isn't it it is wow Effie for you how
did you come to be involved well I
I met you first in 2017 2018 when was it
2018 2018
and you said you are going to produce
our movie and I was like
um you know you have that moment and
then and then like you know a couple
years later I meet them and I'm like do
they not know that I'm gonna do this
movie like holding on to their coattails
like in a real way
um getting the script meeting them it
really seemed like a no-brainer um it
was really dealing with all the issues
that we really hold dear to our hearts
and then being able to bring on these
wonderful people really sort of cinch
the deal
um well you're right because the casting
of this film is so fantastic The
Ensemble from top to bottom well I would
just love to know how you first became
aware of this project and What attracted
you to this role I was in uh Tribeca
film festival in 2018
supporting a film called we the animals
and uh kind of similarly to F he uh
Elegance uh corn and Mia at a party and
uh said I I have I have a script for you
and I have this character for you and
and uh at the time I'd kind of like I
spread myself a little thing I'd said
yes to too many things and I became very
skittish so I kind of I I think I gave
Elegance my number and he texted me and
I kind of ignored the text and then cut
two three years later in 2021 I got the
script uh sent to me by my agency uh
they wanted me to tape for the the role
of Rosales and I read the script and I
thought it was absolutely stunning and
Jeremy for you I mean um what party were
you approached at three years ago
yeah how did you become aware of this
project
um I I was you know I was fortunate to
read the script my agents has sent me
the script
um and I think it was I finished it one
night and then the next day I hopped on
a zoom I was able to meet elegance and I
had so many questions you know I read
this beautiful script about his life but
I wanted to know well what happened
after where where is your mom where
where are you at and you know he he gave
me you know some hard truths as far as
where they were at and what had happened
um and ultimately I think it was just
I knew that by him telling his story in
this way he was going to be giving us so
much and it's one of those vulnerable
things that once you give something so
personal away like this you can't get it
back and I knew that would come at a
cost being a black filmmaker being a
black queer filmmaker so I be I wanted
to be a part of this project to protect
him and kind of be the person in front
um of him because you know I you know it
it just there comes a cost and there's a
lot that he's giving to us
um and that was the journey we began
that Journey after that zoom and I told
him I really want to be a part of this I
think we can make something very special
I am curious if you had been approached
about doing other films or if you were
sort of waiting for something special
yeah
um
you know I I move very specific I think
um I think I say no a lot more
than I do yes I just I'm very sensitive
and I want to work with you know
individuals and creatives that are doing
things a bit different I've been
fortunate to work with a lot of great
collaborators from Broadway to screen
um that allow me to kind of grow and
find and play and that was one thing I
was able to do with this role yes it's
based on his experiences but we kind of
had to have a heart to heart and go out
you have to trust me on this one and I
have to trust you so I could kind of dig
and bring a lot of the things I needed
to bring up to kind of craft this
character together so
um I'm so happy that I said yes to this
one but again I I felt that from the
moment I I read it because it was with
the production company I've been wanting
to work with a24
um and it was just a special story that
sent to the black queer narrative and
growing up I've never seen a black gay
movie star
so I thought wow what a gift for this to
be kind of my entryway into film and be
something that feels so personal but
it's kind of offering healing to this
person that I admire and adore and just
met but I know that this film would be
bigger than just me and him and that it
would resonate with people that needed
to feel seen and heard and know that
they can be the hero and that there is a
way out
well obvious when you see this movie
when why all these people were cast I
mean it is a perfect Ensemble but I am
curious for the producer sort of behind
the scenes what what were you looking
for and how did you go about rounding
out this Ensemble well rounding out I
mean it was um of course Kim Coleman but
it was also you an elegant new from the
beginning of who had what Essence and I
really thought
um you know it was a wonderful ensemble
cast with all the other you know all the
other fellas that are in the movie and I
think when we had that casting process
we knew it when we saw them and then but
the casting process alone getting them
to Mississippi because that's where we
shot in the middle of the summer and oh
yeah those of you know right you know
what I mean and also covid and I think
it was really that some sort of
camaraderie and that sort of bonding
that really sort of gelled into what I
think you see well I hope you see today
you know on the screen this film is is
set in 2005 and I know that's probably
largely because it's autobiographical
um but it's interesting how that doesn't
feel that long ago in some ways but in
other ways the way we looked at
masculinity and the homophobia that was
just so prevalent
um did that sort of contribute to the
choice to make it a period piece
I think it I think it did we he wanted
to tell it drawing don't ask don't tell
and that was during I believe it was
brought to it it happened for the entire
existence of the army but it became a
thing I believe during a book bushes um
Administration yeah and then Obama got
rid of it I believe but um it was really
important that it took place because
there's never been a film that focused
on don't acts don't tell
um any type of uh military film
enroll in Germany I'm so curious because
these characters feel so authentic
having known a lot of military people in
my life
um how did you go about preparing for
these roles was there some sort of a
boot camp or anything like that
there was boot camp
I'm still healing from the real people
that we had it's one of those things
where you're like you know they'll
probably like talk to me about some
things and you know or read a book or
you know something nah yeah we was up at
like I remember reading the call sheet
one morning it was like 3 30 a.m pickup
and I was like for what
like I don't understand what you're
telling me because I'm an actor like I
wanted to make sure like I was getting
the right call sheet and elegance
um was very serious and
we had to show up early morning
um and go through boot camp and you know
just
pull it together
um so I think that definitely led to the
the guys all of us kind of building that
camaraderie as you know as a group as a
as a platoon but yes real boot camp real
push-ups nothing was not real
before we go Jeremy you mentioned that
Elegance was very um generous and you
say you you recognizing that you're
you're playing his story to some extent
but it's also you're creating a
character was it ever challenging though
when you're working alongside the person
that you know the story is so personal I
mean you really don't want to mess it up
and you did it thank you
um I think
you know I think the days that I
remember being just challenging for
everyone in the room
um were any scenes I had with gab who
was playing his mother
um
because it's sensitive and this this
this film was another attempt for him to
reach out to her
um his mother did pass
a few days after the movie was green lit
to go
so there's that there you know there's
that piece and I
just was very sensitive to that fact so
whenever we would get you know we I
remember the one day we got into the
apartment which is basically designed to
look like the apartment that he was
kicked out of so he's having his own
emotional kind of you know Journey with
that
and as I'm getting into character I'm
then realizing there's baby pictures of
me in this space that I kind of went
into my own kind of Journey of feeling
abandoned in my relationship with just
coming out as black and queer and all of
that so
those days were tough
um
and gab kind of having to go to the
place that she had to go to to be able
to find the humanity of this character
and to understand that there is such a
longing between Ellis and his mother but
they just can't quite seem to find each
other that the love that they have for
each other is conditional I can love you
but under these conditions
um so though that was tough time you
know where we really we had to kind of
hold each other and lift each other up
um because there was a lot being poured
into the pot
um but I ultimately knew that at the end
of the day you know once the work was
done that Elegance felt lighter that he
had seen healing that he had felt
lighter
um you know and and and and that's just
all we could be grateful for you know
it's fantastic well again I want to
congratulate you on a beautiful movie
please let everyone know spread the word
about this film it's so special thank
you so much for coming tonight thank you
all so much for being here
[Applause]